[Music]
what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome to another episode of the
rundown where I'm just like hey here is
a really cool story and I really dug it
and you guys should dig it too and this
comes courtesy of the post-civil war
landscape so if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you guys to the sub
button join the Rob core make sure you
guys drop a like and leave a comment let
me know what you guys think so in Marvel
Comics we know that Thor is just like
this powerful guy but but Thor Thor's
like spider-man when it comes to his
strength all right like spider-man pulls
his punches there's been a whole lot of
times when Peter Parker's like dude I
have never hit Doctor Octopus with full
strength because if I did like I I would
knock his head off his shoulders
literally his head would be detached
from his body and that would be the end
of Doctor Octopus why spider-man doesn't
do that I don't know it's fear of a
whole lot of misery if I were spider-man
I just kill my super villains I'd go
home eat some cornflakes you know get
with Mary Jane Watson
have some kids in color today like
that's what I would do all right but you
know I'm not spider-man because
spider-man is not real he as a fictional
character as much as I would like to be
him I cannot be him and I refuse to be
some crazy guy running around dressed as
a spider so Thor is a lot of the same
way our almost never uses his full
strength when he goes into battle
there's only been a handful of times
where he's done that and when he does
man it is it is it is a sight to behold
like it is it is something to see and
this is it this is one of those stories
where Thor it's just unbridled strength
right like it is madness one of the
greatest moments you guys are ever gonna
see man I hope you guys are ready so
prior to Civil War Marvel sat down and
they said okay look we've got Thor and
we've got the Incredible Hulk yes those
Robert Reynolds a century he doesn't
matter because Marvel's done nothing but
screw his character up but he's like
like they're like hey we have we have
Thor we have the Incredible Hulk there's
a two most prominent you know
powerhouses on earth when it comes to
superheroes we cannot have them fight in
Civil War because fans will be like well
whatever side they're on
you know that side is going to win and I
guess you could have put Hulk on one
side and throw on the other but I think
that made too much sense so they were
like let's get rid of them but it's not
bad that they did that because we got
some really good stories like the
Illuminati which is like Charles Xavier
blackballed name
Mariner and few other characters read
Richard so and so forth they were like
do incredible hoaxes just too
unpredictable but no one knows what he's
gonna do you know yes he wants to just
be left alone but we cannot leave him
alone because the plot requires that we
interact with him so that he could have
his own comics so they were like we are
going to send him off planet and he
ended up in the whole Planet Hulk event
really really cool story I highly
suggest check it out I may cover it at
some point in the future ah that
eventually led into world war hope when
he came back and cut a swath of the
superhero community and literally
cleaned house with Thor it was a little
bit of a different story
Marvo for like thirty years had been
teasing Ragnarok right there like her
you never know when Ragnar r's coming
the end of Asgard but we never saw it
like we never really ever saw Ragnarok
come along but that was simply because
Thor was really popular and it didn't
make any sense to kill him off it's like
why would you kill off a really popular
character like that Dec did it with
Superman and it destroyed his comics for
the next 20 years so they were like we
are not going to take that route we are
going to keep Thor alive kind of and so
they had this this event called Thor
Ragnarok or it was part of Avengers
disassembled when the Avengers team
collapsed and stopped being a team and
disbanded Thor experienced Ragnarok now
originally he called Captain America and
Iron Man suicide and he was like hey yo
Bros let's go fight some people because
Loki's taken over Asgard
Odin is dead so he can't help us I'm
kind of on my own here can you guys help
me out and they're like yeah but only
for like an issue because Thor was like
okay now that we basically taken
Ragnarok back or take an ass guard back
I still need you defeat Loki and then
Thor goes on to become rune King Thor I
have a video down about that it's an
awesome moment Thor is like this
Universal threat like it's insane the
amount of power that he has it's crazy
but anyway so with civil we're launching
Thor's out of the equation all right now
what happened is during the Civil War
event Reed Richards and Tony Stark and
Hank Pym had this genius idea they said
hey like Tony Stark you took like a
single strand of Thor's hair right when
you first met him and Iron Man was like
yeah you know because it made sense at
the time
whatever 1960s comics and so he was like
they're like can you clone him from that
and he was I do this is Marvel Comics
Man I can do anything and so like so he
clones him so he clones Thor they make
him a robot then they introduce him as
Ragnarok all right that Ragnarok Thor
guy was crazy like it starts
malfunctioning it kills Goliath you know
like what's your name the one chick from
cloak and dagger dagger is like oh my
god this is
I have no idea what's happening but like
Ryan rocker was saying some awesome
stuff like he was talking some awesome
smack but they ended up decommissioning
him and then they brought him back for a
little while
whatever this whole time Thor like our
Thor the the regular Thor Chris
Hemsworth he was in the land of the
undead like the in-between spaces so he
wasn't really dead but he wasn't really
alive he basically kind of just left the
more of a landscape for a while it was a
way for Marvel to remove him from the
Civil War conflict so fast-forward to
post-civil war right ah like like
Captain America's lost alright he gave
up so he's currently being held in
prison he has not been assassinated yet
the fifty state initiative is in full
effect meaning that there's a superhero
team in all 50 states the out Reed
Richards Tony Stark Hank Pym Carol
Danvers and a few others who were
heading the program and those
individuals who choose not to register
are basically just being rounded up by
shield and being filled thrown in prison
until they choose to agree to follow the
superhuman Registration Act now Thor
ends up coming back he actually came
back during Civil War but he ends up
like officially landfall touches down
you know on earth after Civil War and so
Tony Stark is like oh dude Thor's back
like the real Thor like this is awesome
man so at this point like Tony Stark's
director of shield alright so he's got
like all this power he's like yeah man I
won Civil War you know like he's hot to
trot right like like he's he he comes
rolling up on Thor you know like like
Tony Stark he's like yeah man I'm it
like I'm got the most power of anybody
in the world you know like I've got all
his intelligence and all those power and
technology like you just totally let it
go to his head right so he rolls up on
Thor and he was like hey man and Thor
was like what's up he's like dude it's
good to see you again like I haven't
seen you in forever
yeah and Thor's like Thor Thor just
doesn't really say anything to it and so
Iron Man is like alright here's here's
what's gonna happen dude he was like
these have changed since you've been
gone
alright I'm no longer just this crazy
drunk guy like I'm Iron Man
like I'm the director of shield man you
got to do what I tell you to do alright
and you need to register with shield
because if you don't some bad things are
going to happen you're gonna get hurt
real bad
and so he's like what do you got to say
to that man what do you got to say about
that I'm so Thor's kind of quiet for a
second and Thor's like yeah man you're
right dude
times have changed things are different
now he was like your tracking down
hunting down people that we called
friends during civil war but you you
took it one step further man you cloned
me and that is not okay all right you do
not clone Thor and so so iron man's like
all right fine man he was like you know
I wanted this to be easy I wanted to be
the easy ways like but now I got to put
the entire might a shield behind you let
me tell you something let me tell you
some people Iron Man was not prepared so
Thor grabs his hammer he's just like
boom I mean just like just slams the
hell out of Iron Man right and I man
just like aah aah
this is not what I was expecting to
happen because he's never experienced
going against Thor with his full power
all right so he is a repulsor blasts
right like he shoots his shoe store with
a repulsor blasts and Thor Thor's like
man you better come strong like if
you're gonna come against me man you
better bring your A game
and so Iron Man's all right he's like
let's do this man so he starts punching
Thor you know they start going
toe-to-toe each heart is at him for just
like hits him with his hammer sends him
fly and Thor's not even breaking a sweat
right now right he's just like he's like
whatever man I don't roll up on me you
know with this weak game like you better
bring your A game son you better come
strong so finally you know as they're
going about it again like four shows up
and he was like look man he was like
it's time that you understand the
difference like it's time you understand
your place in the bigger picture he's
like I ain't no normal guy for you to
push over man he's like you may you may
scare all those people out there but you
don't scare me you know and so he's just
like Rick James and then he hits him
with a hammer again right and so they're
like then he grabs him again you know
he's like he's like look man he's like a
Thor damn it
like you don't we don't run upon me you
don't tell me what's going on like you
don't tell me what's happening he was
like after Ragnarok was over like
everybody I knew an ass guard was dead
he's like they've all been reborn in
human bodies and I'm tracking him around
like I'm finding them and I'm freeing
their spirits and I'm rebuilding Asgard
in Oklahoma and a NASCAR is gonna be an
Oklahoma man that's all there is to it
an Iron Man like like he's terrified for
his life because he's like dude I've
never seen Thor this pissed off before
like I've never seen him this strong
before he's like I'm just I
was not prepared and so so Iron Man's
like uh hey man in light of recent
events the recent events being I just
got my ass kicked
you are welcome to have Asgard in
Oklahoma just make sure it levitates off
the ground and uh that so it's not
touching the soil of the earth or the
soil of the United States so it's not
considered to be part of United States
is considered sovereign territory and
you do not need to worry about
registering and Thor is like oh I know
he's like you're not telling me anything
I don't already know
he was like but let me tell you
something man he was like you go back to
all those folks that you answer to those
presidents and those politicians those
military guys like you tell him he's
like if they come knocking on this on
this door right here he's like man
because I you know they don't get a
whole lot worse than they bargained for
he's like he's like I'm gonna take him
behind the woodshed that's exactly what
he said he's like I'm gonna take him
behind the woodshed you know and I'm
gonna show him the time of their life
like they wouldn't believe he's like I
will bring them a war like like they
can't even imagine you know and and so
so he sends them off he's like that's it
man he was like understand your place in
the bigger picture you know he was like
you you are you are a normal man he's
like I am a God he's like I could end
you and your whole race at any point in
time if I wanted to I just don't feel
like it at the moment because I've got
more important things to do like eat
some cornflakes
so with that being said guys let me know
what you think about this this comic
it's actually pretty awesome I highly
suggest you guys check it out
it's a great conflict between Thor and
Iron Man one of my favorites it's really
just it's totally start being put in his
place after he became the director of
shield realizing just because he's
director of shield does it mean if he's
got power over everybody so with that
being said we're gonna bring this to an
end and yeah I will catch you guys later
peace
you
[Music]